yours looks like a meal mine literally
looks like a mom that was frantic in the
morning that just like took everything
out of a package no I am Lauren and I'm
representing Korea I'm Nate
I'm representing America I'm Emily I am
representing the United States of
America today I'm eating song I'm
representing Korea and today we're
swapping school lunches growing up
school lunches were kind of gross
it certainly wasn't gourmet there's a
lot of like microwave pizza french fries
just like she's literally just like
she's Korean school lunches are very
healthy they always had kimchi like some
kind of meat kids have better food at
school then sometimes at their house
it's very much the opposite in my
experience well I'm pretty hungry I'm
starving great yeah let's let's swap
room
here's America I think that's an
Uncrustables effing we think that have
some sort of television show before it
oh wow breathe
your lungs fantastic where's that did
you watch to all the boys of course yeah
that is what it's worth the hype as you
can see we've got sugar there's sugar in
here sugar in there sugar in there this
is like quite literally what the people
like a baby
essentially yeah yeah it's like dough
with some yeah salad has ranch and then
there's a side of extra ranch on the
side some corn as you can see right we
got some like fruit peaches it looks
like that has been soaking in syrup
probably for like a couple of months
some wet carrots that were also probably
soaking in some juices for a couple
months have you ever had one of these
mm-hmm okay you do so typically in a
Korean lunch we have the white rice the
soup and like the punch I would include
like vegetables or meat basically eggs
mixed in with some vegetables and then
more vegetables and then some meat and
we have some punch on over here looks
like some marinated cucumbers it looks
like we just kind of like
bean sprouts yeah yeah bring bean
sprouts oh we got some carrots going on
here and it looks like we have some Goza
we have some shrimp fried shrimp and I
believe it's like a frightened and then
this is milk Oh combined with some fish
in there too
what's more cool Meo cook is like a
seaweed soup Oh a lot of people hate it
when it's their birthday and my
birthday's coming up soon and it looks
like we have ten jungle care it's like a
staple Korean soup and then you got
you'll go to two which is like a sweet
little drink so your sugar comes in like
a tiny little container and ours comes
in like a bread pouch oh boy so excited
should we cheers absolutely let's do it
this is an event
let me yep take you to so it's very
little spongy little enjoy it thank you
oh this is really good that would go
really well with the Uncrustables I do
actually like Uncrustables mmm healthy I
mean I'm not mad at it
she's embraced okay like it's not bad if
I wasn't like a starving child I would
not be mad I'm interested in this
birthday sue that's got a good okay I
got kick to it yeah okay you have this
for your birthday uh yeah that's
delicious
I'm gonna try some of this vegetable
medley going in my belly
what did I tell you mm-hmm I could eat I
think like one thing for the rest of my
life would it be that I might be but you
say this is fried chicken yeah that's a
bit more my speed that's a bit more
american-style
we got fruit dipped in lots of I think
syrup or something have a peach yet you
know I probably should what's your
hesitation no I'm not okay I'm ready
cheese I know what cheese tastes like
I'm not really sure what I'm eating
yeah good little peach are you sure I
mean I I was confident and now I'm yeah
this fried chickens really good I like
it is this like also considered like a
healthy thing because it feels kind of
like recently that's our little cheat
this is the chief okay I think you guys
have like one food that's the cheap food
and everything else is pretty healthy
and we have like one thing that's pretty
healthy and everything else is kind of
cheap food
what's healthier the carrots okay I feel
like I'm complaining a lot you were
saying you are experienced uh and it
just so happens to be a little bit worse
than my nose look at my carrot and look
at like your hair I know egg it's like
yeah there's like a little omelette that
gets prepared for you and then what
about the vegetable yeah what'd you say
these were that's spinach spinach oh wow
okay wait you guys get spinach for lunch
again what is this one called again
this is a ton the meat tongue oh wait I
just saw the cross-section I would be so
much healthier as a person if this is
what I was eating when I was a child
Oh your school isn't they were spoiled
as children yeah
damn I would be like energized I'd be
empowered and have a great day after
this all right trip time that's a big
chunk Wow that's really good I've never
had a soup that tastes like that I think
this is like bean paste I've never had
this before
there we go
and you're getting a probiotics so good
good would you like that yeah please I
can't stand watching you suffer
I haven't had this in a hot minute
finish it finish it yeah
my childhood is litter it's really good
yeah oh yeah it was great I didn't know
that's like the standard of food yeah
pun time I think the American term is
slop it's a slop of salad and a sloppy
Korean lunch is incredible what a mime
what a lunch I wish that our our lunches
were a little bit better I think they're
getting better now but I wish when I was
a kid I had it even better I would
probably not change anything about my
childhood after that meal but I love
pizza and I love peaches and I'm not
gonna complain if I did were up here but
you did it but I did not know because I
would sweep hey better late than never
mid 20 was the perfect time to do it all
over
[Music]